JOHN ESSIGMANN: There are
many different treatments
for diabetes.
I'll just use myself
as a case study.
One of the things
I did to myself
is I measure my blood sugar at
different times during the day,
and my blood sugar
this morning was 116.
And my blood sugar at about
five o'clock this afternoon
will probably be in
the high 80s or 90.
My blood sugar after I have a
meal might go up to 160, 170,
and it shouldn't go that high.
And some mornings, like
a couple of days ago,
my blood sugar was
146, which is too high.
And that reflects two things,
what I ate the night before,
but the second thing
is the one that's
my problem, which
is gluconeogenesis.
Gluconeogenesis technically
means new synthesis of glucose
from non-carbohydrate
precursors.
For example, I could take
the amino acid aspartate,
and I could find a path by
which I could convert that
into glucose.
I could take lactate, and I
could convert it into glucose.
OK, so during the day, I use
my glucose, and I stay active,
and I walk around.
I ride my bike and so on.
So my glucose level, it's
pretty reasonable by the time
I go to bed.
But then at night, when I
stop moving around a lot,
this gluconeogenesis
process continues in me,
and that's what causes
my blood sugar to go up.
The medicine I take
is called Metformin.
It has a number of
targets, but one of them
is one of the enzymes, called
PEPCK, Pyruvate Carboxykinase,
that's in the
gluconeogenic pathway.
Let me say a word about
gluconeogenesis, another word
actually.
So we all have dinner, like say
six to nine o'clock at night.
We go to bed, and there
are certain organs
in the body, the
brain, our red blood
cells, that require glucose.
They can't work
with anything else.
So gluconeogenesis, by
principally the liver,
provides a constant
stream of glucose
to these organs that absolutely
require it, like our brain.
Now, when we go to sleep at
night, as time gets longer
and longer and longer,
after the meal,
our glucose level, our
natural glucose level,
is going to start to fall off.
And the liver then
compensates by increasing
the amount of
gluconeogenesis in order
to keep our blood
glucose at about 100
while we're not eating.
What I do, during the night,
is to take this drug that
will prevent the switch to
produce more and more sugar
by gluconeogenesis.